I do feel like a lot of spirituality is
needed to try out the trend in our next
story and Kevin is back with us from New
York and I just want to know I'm Kevin
what would you like us to book your
snake massage I know it sounds ludicrous
but I'm telling you this is the story
that all you viewers will be talking
about with your friends tomorrow
look massages are all about relaxing the
mind and body but could you do that with
boa constrictors crawling all over you
we had our producer Darla Murray find
out when you encounter a snake feel a
multitude of complex and powerful
reactions ok this is on my head
and because we crave meaningful
experiences felt through our senses it's
like aa deep bliss this hold on me
serpent Tessa a snake priestess who got
her start charming serpents 35 years ago
though I was doing belly dance and I was
involved with music someone offered me
my first snake since then this snake
Queen has introduced her brood of boas
to thousands of people one of her most
recent clients looking for some reptile
relaxation Victoria's Secret model
Stella Maxwell she had never met snakes
before so she had some questions
Stella's not the only one
first up why do this instead of a
regular massage serpent Tessa says the
creatures create an adrenaline rush they
stimulate the vagus nerve and they which
releases oxytocin and endorphins the
feel-good hormones gotta love them I
think the weight and this is nice almost
like a weighted blanket they're warmer
than I thought many many clients tell me
that the snakes will go to areas of
their body that they need healing and
there's and that's often in the neck
area and if you're terrified of snakes
serpent Tessa says she's helped people
overcome their fears but is this really
safe
they have never hurt anybody you know
I've been bitten occasionally when I
feed well that's a different lesson
altogether still a session with serpent
Tessa will take a bite out of your
wallet
it starts at 300 bucks for a 75
it massage there's a snake on my face
but overall it is quite relaxing
unbelievable she survived this is garlic
here with us now I'm tell the truth
would you do it again okay first of all
that was probably the weirdest thing
I've ever done but so cool watching it
back was actually scarier probably cuz I
had my eyes closed the whole you're
shaking a little bit
no way cannot believe I did that so
would I do it again if you come with me
so you're not doing it again okay but I
do have an idea though the next time
you're in New York Nancy you and dollar
should hook up and know what do you know
you meet now Nancy
oh no no hot stone massage is as
dangerous as I go Darla you're my new
hero
[Music]